this is a production of cornell
university
so i'll be discussing my research and
detecting genetic and local
environmental effects using
high-throughput
aerial imagery there's a
long history of satellite and airplane
imagery
for applications in agriculture
for example in 1972
when the united states launched um
landsat
1 uh the satellite into orbit
that enabled a lot of remote sensing
applications to to begin and for
instance the
vegetation indices to be developed
um our applications for genetic
improvement
in plant breeding have been hindered by
the cost the resolution of the imagery
and repeatability due to weather or
other positioning problems when you want
to image
the same field throughout the growing
season
so today we have a low low-cost and
stable platform
in the form of unoccupied aerial
vehicles or uavs
and this enables high-resolution images
it's scalable in that a single pilot
or operator can fly um many fields
in one day and and could potentially fly
every day of
the growing season and for instance i
flew
uh 18 flights this summer
of a field in aurora and 28 flights of
alfalfa here in ithaca and and many
others
and i use um or we use the the
microsense multi-spectral camera which
captures in the blue green red red edge
and near infrared
spectra so you can see the camera here
with the five
distinct lenses um
and the thing to remember is to you have
to take a
picture of this calibration panel prior
to flying
and post processing i i do two i follow
two steps
um the first is to generate on ortho
photo mosaic
using fix 4d um i want to
explore using open drone map because
it's a open source
software um then the second step
is to upload those orthophotomosaics to
imagery
for this website i have imagery.org
um so this is a doctor deployable
uh software so you can set up an
instance on your own
um computer if you wanted it's
open source and it houses
all the field genotypic data
and analyses
so in 2019 we have this genomes to
fields
field this was 232
hybrid planted over 500 plots
and with nick kasmor in san antonio we
got
six lights um if you look closely you
can see the
red and blue lines for the plot
delineations
um zooming in you can see the plot these
plot polygons
and um you can see it's fairly high
resolution
and each of these plot polygons is saved
in
the database um i went ahead and
calculated vegetation indices for each
plot
for each time point so i have ndvi
ndre tgi and vari
these vegetation indices are nice
because they're
they're derived simply from means of
images but in the future i want to
find phenotypes that can better capture
features that are late in the image
so that's for a future project
but once i have these phenotypes i
use linear mixed models to
separate genetic from environmental
effects so
for the fixed effect i account for the
replicate
um in the field for the genetic effect
i use um genomic relationships that are
calculated from
close to a million gbs markers that were
genotyped for the parents of these
hybrids
and the random environmental effects can
either
be or spatial effects
or permanent environment effects
so going a little bit deeper into the
the models that i'm looking at
i'm looking at three different classes
of linear mix
models the first class is
is the spatial effects so it can be a
two-dimensional spline
or an auto regressive process and this
class of
linear mix model um
takes information from the rows and the
columns of the plots in the field
and um so then the second class is these
temporal effects or permanent
environment effects and they're
computed using a random regression
and the third class is a random
regression
but i can incorporate um
either spatial effects or
soil survey information or or any
plot to plot correlation structure um
[Music]
could be incorporated in that two-step
random or into that random regression
the outputs of these um models
uh are what you see on the right so
i'll have genetic effects for
each line across time so
each line represents the hybrid and
x-axis is time and
why it accesses the genetic effect and
also
as you see on the bottom right um
i'll have
[Music]
the environmental effect across time so
these are heat
like snapshots of the field of the plots
in the field
over time
and the the random regression has benef
many benefits
um including that it fits a continuous
covariance function
across all the time points so you can
essentially evaluate the genetic or
environmental effect at any given time
point
and it can fit um large numbers of time
points which
multi-trait models um could have
convergence issues with
so with these models um it's there's
still a question of
which one is capturing the effects
um truly and since we don't know
either the genetic or a true genetic or
environmental effect
i i can use simulation um so this is a
three-step
approach where i first take one of those
models
and i minimize the local environment
effect
um or for using real data
then the second step is to add in a
simulated
known effect and the third is to
observe which of these models can most
accurately detect
the the simulated effect
so this is a work in progress and
i should soon have results for
and lastly i want to look if
soil survey uh information can
explain some of the variation this this
local environmental variation
and in 2019 we we have a
electrical conductance measurements and
altitude measurements
that were measured by
nick casmar and so on the left here you
see electrical conductance
and on the right altitude and we can
also compute
like first and second derivatives of of
that of those measurements
so try to account for curvature of the
of the soil or curvature of the field
which is known to be a a source of
variation so in closing
um uavs allow for low-cost
high-resolution phenotypes
image breed can be used to quickly
extract
plot-level phenotypes linear mixed
models can separate
genetic from spatial and temporal or
permanent environment effects
in the field i can use simulation to
probe which model
best captures the true effect
and um soil survey info may
provide um insight into the source of
the effect
so i want to thank my committee um kelly
ellie robbins lucas mueller harold
vanessa and jogens
and um here i'm just
um these are the flights i took in in
this year of the alfalfa so
i'm looking forward to analyzing that
also
so thank you awesome thank you nick for
that great talk
um if anybody has any questions
the chat is open
uh hey nick this is jean-luc um this is
probably an impossible question to
answer but
can you explain briefly the difference
between uh
this the spline model and an auto
aggressive model i'm kind of familiar
with auto aggressive
not too familiar with splines yeah
so the autoregressive assumes a fixed
correlation between uh all of the plots
in the field so
um if you move away one unit of distance
from a plot
you'll follows a correlation
of you know it has a fixed correlation
and if you move away two units it's that
correlation squared
three units a correlation q
um but with the spline it fits a
function um it solves for coefficients
for
linear splines so like it's a
linear equation of the rows and columns
and
their interactions so
i don't know if that answers but
uh thanks yeah that's helpful
okay well thank you and yeah feel free
to
email me or ask me a question
awesome thank you again nick
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu